et on va maintenant parler d'une toute
autre oeuvre donc c'est celle-ci n'est
pas immersive mais elle permet toutefois
au téléspectateur pardon de voir les
coulisses de la télévision alors David
Fargeon vous êtes le confondateur de la
compagnie légende urbaine et vous êtes
metteur en scène de la pièce c'est un
sentiment qu'il faut que nous
combattions je crois alors cette pièce
propose je cite ce que j'avais trouvé
aussi c'est de démonter le mythe d'une
certaine vision de la banlieue portée
par les médias aujourd'hui quel constat
vous faites justement à l'égard de la
couverture médiatique des banlieues
aujourd'hui
je m'attendais pas celle-là non mais non
mais non très sincèrement je m'attendais
pas à ça là parce que effectivement nous
on le document qu'on utilise
principalement et qu'on qu'on analyse
tout au long du spectacle il a dû 2016
donc il a il a un certain nombre
d'années aujourd'hui
et que aujourd'hui moi je regarde plus
du tout la télé mais comme beaucoup de
personnes enfin que le rapport aux
médias il a il a vraiment il a vraiment
beaucoup changé
le bâton parce que justement vous
regardez plus la télé par rapport
justement à ça ou c'est pour autre chose
non ça fait évidemment partie des
raisons et
mais après je pense que c'est aussi une
évolution de consommateur d'informations
voilà entre les réseaux sociaux les
nouveaux médias etc où on on n'est plus
là dedans mais moi lou ça me semble
intéressant de de de revenir de revenir
comment fonctionne le journal alisme
télévisuel c'est que il est un peu à la
matrice aussi d'une façon de produire de
l'information d'une façon de produire du
regard de et de fabriquer du récit et
que sur les chaînes d'infos on continue
sur certaines d'entre elles en tout cas
avec un axe éditorial voir idéologique
assez clairement d'un côté de
l'échiquier politique
Marsa vient pas de nulle part en fait et
de là Mao parlait
d'un spectacle qui revient sur un
événement historique et qui essaye de
décrypter par l'archive etc là on est
sur un événement sur sur une histoire un
peu moins ancienne mais c'est toujours
intéressant je trouve de revenir aussi
voilà à l'origine nous moi je date on
aime bien qu'il a date de 81 pour
commencer à parler de ce qu'on nomme le
mythe médiatique des banlieues 81 c'est
les Minguettes c'est les rodéodes des
linguettes à Vénissieux c'est ce qu'on
avait nommé l'été chaud des Minguettes
et c'est à partir de ce moment là où
pendant un mois et demi on voit des
voitures brûlées dans la banlieue de
Lyon pendant un mois et demi tous les
soirs au journal de 20 heures et que ça
ça va profondément marquer un imaginaire
collectif et ça va ancrer quelque chose
d'une image de ce que serait les
banlieues françaises de ce que serait le
quartier populaire français marqué par
voilà des voitures qui brûlent déjà qui
sont potentiellement dangereux du
désœuvrement de l'immigration de tout un
tas de thématiques
dont on sature aujourd'hui mais qui
était déjà très présente il y a plus de
40 ans alors pour réaliser cette pièce
de théâtre où vous décidez de recréer
cet univers de la télé avec de la
lumière des caméras un plateau pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez fait ce choix alors
ce choix il est fait parce que moi ce
qui m'amuse au théâtre c'est que on est
sur un art finalement relativement
archaïque de fabriquer de la
représentation on a un plateau des
acteurs des spectateurs qui sont en face
de nous et à partir de là on va jouer
des personnages on va fabriquer du décor
euh alors à l'inverse de fabriquer du
décor avec trois francs suisses ou et
moi ça m'a et ça ça m'amuse beaucoup ça
et ça m'amuse d'autant plus quand on
peut aller convoquer un autre
vocabulaire et que ben là le vocabulaire
qui est utilisé sur ce plateau là le
type de lumière le type de rapport qu'on
a vous et moi les caméras qui sont qui
sont là la manière dont en régie ils
vont décider de faire le montage etc etc
et ben tout ça ça va produire de la
forme produire du récit et nous le fait
de réutiliser ce même dispositif sur
scène c'est à dire que sur scène on a
effectivement trois caméras on a un banc
de montage vidéo on monte à vue on filme
et on monte à vue pendant le temps de
l'argumentation c'est les comédiens qui
le font et Ben et ben du coup on peut
s'amuser à
déconstruire la façon dont sont
fabriqués des représentations et voilà
il y a quelque chose de très ludique
là-dedans finalement et si on revient un
peu plus justement sur l'histoire de
cette pièce
déjà il y a combien de comédiens sur
scène et qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir y
apprendre en regardant cette pièce alors
on est si comédien sur scène parce que
je joue dedans également on est six au
plateau
et en gros moi j'aime à dire qu'on fait
du tas de documenté c'est à dire que on
fait un théâtre ou
11 documents beaucoup on lit on lit
beaucoup enfin on essaye de s'emparer un
sujet le journaliste on n'est pas
journaliste aucun d'entre nous n'est
journaliste donc on prend un vrai temps
pour se documenter sur cette profession
et sur les modes de production de la
formation etc
mais là où je dis documenté c'est que
pour moi c'est important que les acteurs
les actrices
d'où on parle
moi si je si je travaille depuis plus de
15 ans sur la banlieue c'est en tant que
banlieusard et que moi en tant que
banlieusard
j'ai envie de de proposer d'autres
récits que les récits dominants et que
tous les acteurs les actrices du
spectacle ils viennent pas tous de
banlieues mais par contre ils ont tous
un regard et leur regard il a été
façonné justement par les médias
et donc il y a
le spectacle qui est vraiment décomposé
en 5 chapitres et chaque chapitre est
ponctué par un solo d'un acteur ou d'une
actrice qui raconte qui met en jeu d'où
elle d'où elle parle et je pense à enfin
je pourrais en citer plusieurs mais
il y en a ou ben la comédienne explique
que elle elle arrive en région
parisienne elle vient de Provence et
elle arrive en 2005 elle arrive en 2005
elle est étudiante en 2005 elle démarre
à Paris et qu'est-ce qu'elle voit elle
voit les émeutes et elle se dit et dans
un truc qui sature qui est ultra
anxiogène et qui se dit ben voilà elle
arrive là et d'un seul coup elle arrive
dans cette ville et et il y a un gap
entre ce qu'elle vit ce qu'elle voit à
la télé et que ça ben voilà ça c'est un
truc ben voilà ça raconte tout ça par
exemple mais justement vous parlez de
façonner le regard
mais j'imagine aussi que pour la
jeunesse qui regarde la télé ils peuvent
avoir aussi cette imaginaire collectif
et ce qu'en regardant votre pièce un
jeune peut-être de un jeune adolescent
peut comprendre facilement la pièce et
pouvoir conscientiser aussi le message
que vous que vous souhaitez faire passer
ouais c'est un spectacle on l'a créé en
2019 en lui aussi il a été interrompu
par le covid etc mais bon ça fait un
certain nombre d'années qu'on tourne et
qui fonctionne très bien avec les
lycéens qui fonctionnent très bien avec
avec les collégiens on va dire à partir
de 3e et qu'on a des bords plateaux des
échanges des ateliers en classe avec
avec les élèves
on sent que il y a
il y a quelque chose il y a quelque
chose qui qui se produit et et en
échange et une rencontre et aussi quand
qu'on intervient dans des classes
de quartiers plus ou moins populaires
de se dire qu'à un moment donné
c'est un spectacle j'espère qu'on essaye
de rendre une certaine dignité à cette
jeunesse là qui qui peut par moment se
sentir un postigmatisé un peu pointé du
doigt et de leur dire mais en fait
ça fait du bien ouais ça fait du bien
vous existez et vous pouvez être aussi
les acteurs de vos propres rythmiques
vous pouvez aussi raconter
vos histoires et à votre manière
merci David Fargeon d'être venus chez
tv78 pour nous parler de votre pièce de
théâtre on le rappelle et se jouera sur
la scène de l'Espace Coluche à Plaisir
vendredi 26 mai du coup ça parle de
notre neutralité et une thématique qui
nous est chère en tant que journaliste
merci à vous